[Music]
for many students one reason to get a
college degree is to have the chance to
make a good living but for most a degree
also means debt this year about 70
percent of college students graduated
with student loan debt averaging around
$33,000 per student and totaling more
than 1.6 trillion dollars nationwide one
innovative high school program is
preparing students to move straight into
good-paying jobs without a college
degree or even trade school Barry
Petersen talked to students
participating in this job market
jumpstart it looks like an aircraft
maintenance hangar but it isn't or a
real hospital room not that either and
yes this is a fully equipped auto repair
shop and let us know when you have a
good connection with some cars are right
off the assembly line
what else is dangerous under here but
these aren't mechanics not yes they are
students at an unusual high school
called the Cherry Creek innovation
campus where a 16 year old Taylor Odin
has a plane go from high school to work
my mom wasn't very ecstatic about it
would rather me go to college and so is
my dad but understands that you don't
need to go to college to be successful
nowadays and at Auto Service facilities
like this one for Rickenbacker de Lac in
downtown Denver mechanics salaries can
get high says service manager Blais
flirty you could do as well as $100,000
or plus with the right shop the right
amount of work the
education and the right amount of
dedication wow that's more than coal the
school opened this year a forty three
million dollar custom-built facility
with specialized classroom
like this fully equipped restaurant
kitchen designed to mimic real-world
settings the learning is hands-on
students are volunteers and must also
attend and pass regular high school
classes to get their to plumb and while
some students may go on to college
others here would go right to jobs that
was a tough sell for principal mark
Morgan I get the sense that a lot of
parents are not always comfortable with
the idea of not going from high school
right to college and so for parents
we're really trying to educate as well
that what really matters is having a
successful plan where a student will
graduate high school and go into a
career where they can be happy and
healthy and something that can sustain
them the most popular class is four
months of training to be a certified
nurse's aide teacher Melissa leg is a
registered nurse that certification exam
once they pass it they have it in their
hand they can go to that employer and
say I'm certified to work as a CNA and a
hospital home how long-term care you
have you name it what's the demand for
these students in terms of people
looking to hire them they want them
yesterday basically it took a lot of
work to create an aircraft mechanics
class first they needed aircraft they
bought a used 1981 helicopters and two
planes that were flown to a nearby
airport and then at dawn on a Sunday
morning towed to the school do you think
would happen with that debt right there
we take this part off and then just
research them I guess Thor Barlow is a
senior what does it mean to you Thor to
have this kind of opportunity to learn
by doing I absolutely love it I'm a very
visual learner I'm a very hands-on
learner okay you can go inside like you
can see all this open engines you can
see how all that works how fits together
how this doesn't work at all you can
either affect just a little bit of the
engine or the
thing and the school got FAA approval to
graduate certified aircraft mechanics
training and instructor David Williamson
says can be very pricey if these kids
had to go to a school what would it cost
them to get this certification about
forty thousand dollars really really and
this is basically free basically for you
yes sir and are there jobs out there
when they walk out of here yeah there's
plenty of jobs out there another skill
students learn how to succeed after
they've landed a job so 30% of every
student's grade on this campus is about
professional skills it goes to work
ethic showing up to work on time what it
means to truly collaborate what it means
to lead and to be led and that's the
real lesson taught here that success to
be a good career with good pay and doing
what you love CBS this morning Saturday
Barry Petersen Centennial Colorado
if you ever see online it'll say like
here are the six jobs that pay a lot you
don't know a lot of these jobs are in
there and not for everyone it's not
always about learning to a certain
degree it's the job that they want and
you have to give them that up think
about it our electricians or plumbers I
mean there are the service people
mechanics all of those you don't
necessarily have to go to college for
and we need them right we need them
desperately and they make well over six
figures you can still learn you can
still read and do other things out